mucha expectativa para el primer debate
electoral en brasil todo apunta a que
los dos principales contrincantes el ex
presidente luiz inácio lula da silva y
el actual presidente jair bolsonaro van
a estar presentes recordamos que
evolucionaron no participó en ninguno de
los debates de la segunda vuelta en 2018
que inicialmente había dicho que no
estaría presente lula por su parte dijo
que sólo participaría si estaría
presente en bolsonaro finalmente el 1
decidió salir del impasse y ayer en sus
redes sociales confirmó su participación
acto seguido bolsonaro dijo que también
iría lo hice en un programa de radio
aunque su equipo no ha confirmado
siempre si en su participación esto
quiere decir que puede haber una
sorpresa hasta el último momento en
principio estarán presentes seis de los
dos ex candidatos a las elecciones sin
embargo todos los ojos están puestos
precisamente en los dos favoritos
lula con el 47% de la intención de voto
según el último sondeo y personaron con
el 32% de intención de voto el debate
empezará a las nueve de la noche horario
de brasil tendrá una duración aproximada
de tres horas estará dividido en tres
bloques y se espera que entre los temas
que serán abordados estará la crisis
económica la vuelta del hambre y con
seguridad también la corrupción